parmi papa mon papa m'a pas mis sa femme
pam a annoncé racheter je vais
recommencer bon attention
peu 3 4 1 2 3 4 non c'est pas encore ça
ah la la
tian bonjour
j'étais tellement occupés à régler un
nouveau pas de danse que je ne vous
avais pas vus
regardez je vais vous montrer je suis
surpris quand je vais le réussir cette
fois
2 3 4
c'était mieux et
vous savez 1 c'est un des pas de danse
qui fait le plus rire le facteur emile
campagne j'adore faire rire le facteur
d'ailleurs j'aime faire rire tout le
monde mais vous savez c'est pas toujours
facile pour trouver quelque chose comme
ça ou alors comme ça eh bien il ça
demande beaucoup de répétitions oui
il fait vraiment très beau aujourd'hui
dans l'île aux enfants n'est ce pas
j'ai envie de faire un jeu vous êtes
d'accord ouais bon alors on regarde à
quoi est ce que l'on pourrait bien jouer
écouter on va aller demander à françois
deux soirs au vert en soit c'est
messi d'état de faire un jeu avec tous
nos amis ne le croit reconnaître d'état
que tu nous elle fait que tu viens de
jouer avec nous quasiment
j'ai bien un truc du temps arrêterait
jamais
4 et malheureusement non casimir non non
j'aimerais bien venir jouer avec vous
tous mais aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment un
travail fou du travail évidemment j'ai
reçu une commande importante de ballons
de monsieur du snob qui organise une
petite fête chez lui alors il faut que
je les gonfle que je fixe les baguettes
métalliques et je suis pas prêt d'avoir
fini et c'est du travail tout ça qui va
évidemment
le travail d'un marchand de ballons
cette conf laisser ballon le mieux
possible pour qui se dégonfle pas et de
les vendre bricmont alors je te laisse
parce que le travail c'est ça que tu as
très bien compris merci casimir mehdi
dont si je finis à tôt je viendrai jouer
avec vous à tout à l'heure d'accord à
tout à l'heure arai bien à l'homme papam
patent papam julie fallu casimir et
excuse moi mais que j'ai je suis
complètement débordé à 90 je voudrais
que tu viens jouer avec moi et que nos
amis qui attendent on va faire un jeu un
homme j'aurais bien aimé c'est dommage
mais j'ai un travail terrible du travail
moi aussi et par oui j'ai beaucoup de
travail et c'est pour que les enfants de
l'île où les visiteurs trouvent ce
qu'ils veulent dans le cas il faut que
je fasse des commandes aux fabricants de
jouets aux usines de bonbons et de
limonade et puis après pour donner
aussitôt à ceux qui viennent ceux qui le
désirent il faut que je range tout bien
dans le kiosque ouais ça doit pas être
facile surtout quand tu mélanges
toujours les caramels est les bonbons à
la groseille
il faut avouer que je ne suis pas très
ordonnée mais à la fin je me retrouve
toujours c'est le principal enfin sorte
je te demande une gaffeuse en soi quand
tu me donnes d'abord la glace et quand
le temps que tu trouves les anchois la
glace a fondu et coutts elles s'est
produit qu'une fois et je te promets que
ça ne se reproduira plus tu sais où tu
as rangé les anchois maintenant non mais
je chercherai les os x d'abord et je te
donnerai la glace ensuite bon tu es
gentil hein tu me laisse travailler
parce que monsieur du snob organise une
fête il m'a commandé pour ses invités
des petits paquets avec eux un caramel
paris glisse un nougat une sucette et un
bon bout fourrés à la framboise
ça doit être ça c'est clair bon bah
alors je te laisse tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que ce serait ah bonjour
facteur
bouton est sable bonjour j j ai bien le
chemin pour venir jusqu'ici embaume le
parfum des fleurs c'est vraiment très
agréable de travailler quand l'air est
doux comme aujourd'hui vous travaillez
vous aussi
sur mes portes et des lettres d'une
personne à une autre ainsi que des colis
tu sais c'est vraiment un travail très
important ouais bon ben alors bon
courage ce facteur merci a bientot année
l effet de levier
olalalala c'est terrible tout le monde
travaille dans l'île aux enfants il y a
que moi qui ne fait rien et je ne fais
rien parce que parce que je ne sais pas
je suis bien contente j'ai terminé vous
travaillez moi aussi il faut bien dire
que rien ne procure plus de joie quel
travail bien fait on pense à mon sens
triste qu'est-ce qu'il ya casimir pour
coup et tutrice c'est ça que françoise
viens de lire je vois pas en quoi la
joie que procure le travail bien fait un
peu trop triste mais parce pas sourire
aux enfants je suis le seul qui ne
travaillent pas un qui trompe qui fait
au contraire le plus beau travail de
toute l'île aux offshore quoi qu'est ce
que c'est françois raison au travail
c'est de faire rimer jouer et qu'il fait
très bien et tout à l'heure c'est je
t'aime lyrique ont dû répéter les pas de
danse des formidables fiva alors quand
je viens pour m'amuser c'est du travail
absolument
julie tu as le temps alors on va
travailler pour les yeux d'accord je les
enfants chercher mon ami 0 venez avec
moi on va regarder julie et casimir
entraînements c'est d'accord l'euro
s'installe sur le dos voilà aux
premières loges et c
[Musique]
waouh
il
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
elle
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà on ouvre le casque ça va coûter
chers amis bonjour je veux dire à
monsieur du snav voilà une surprise
bonjour cher comment allez vous serez
bien chers amis j'ai passé hier une
soirée divine avec des gens d'une
qualité intellectuelle tout à fait
remarquable est que fit vous au cours de
cette soirée j'ai lu quelques-unes de
mes poèmes une autre succès mon ami
j'aurais voulu que vous soyez là les
dames ne pouvait retenir leurs larmes
tellement elle est
à vous avez trouvé le mot sur une charge
lui c'était grandiose comme celle du
snad que phil woods outre cours de cette
grande soirée allemand parlé par le fait
d'y repenser j'ai le coeur qui
défaillent
la charmante demoiselle coloquintes de
tous nous a interprété
10 ont essayé le raid a prêté en
s'accompagnant elle même au piano une
charmante mélodies hautement
philosophique intitulé assis les oiseaux
faisaient leur nid avec des bétons on
aurait du petit bois pour l'hiver laisse
pas ravi son décès ces bouleversements
mais dites moi monsieur du secondaire ii
vous avez dû me coucher très tard à mon
cher ami alors je viens juste de me
lever quelles démarches qu'on veut nous
au contraire nous avons profité d'une
merveilleuse journée et avec le chant
des petits oiseaux qui gentils mots
venaient retirer toutes les branches du
jardin pour faire leurs nids
détruits rami c'est un avantage auquel
je n'avais pas pensé il faudra que je
conseille à cette charmante colloque est
de tout d'abandonner son idée denis
embêté monsieur dees pas vous voulez
quelque chose à boire non veut
décidément très gentil merci chère julie
je viens seulement par kasimi aidez-moi
envoyé un petit mot pour vous donner
rendez vous n'avez pas vu non justement
à nous il avait promis d'être là et nous
attendons en vain
bonjour casimir on joue sinon à quand
une affaire de moeurs tu sais on est
toujours de bonne humeur quand on va
faire une bonne action ça c'est très
vrai et elle est cette bonne action eh
bien j'ai décidé de vous faire un cadeau
à tous les trois parce que vous êtes
tellement gentil avec moi mais c'est
qu'on t'aime beaucoup casimir le faisons
là rien d'extraordinaire
mais si si si j'y tiens beaucoup et puis
ça me fait tellement plaisir mais
dis-moi casimir pourquoi aujourd'hui
sans aucune raison a si justement il y a
une très bonne raison laquelle eh bien
j'ai tout rangé chez moi et j'ai
retrouvé les objets dont je ne savais
pas quoi faire alors au lieu de les
jeter à la poubelle j'ai pensé vous les
données d obala destinés à être jetés
aux ordures bah tu vois j'attendais
mieux mais mon sac et finir tous s'ils
sont vraiment nous offrir des objets que
tu voulais mettre à la poubelle newey
alors mon voeu que du mur quand on veut
faire un cadeau ou neuf chez pas mal et
des jolies choses qu'on aimerait bien
garder pour soi et pas des vieux objets
tout casser dont on veut plus on fera du
coin bon j'en suis sûr la compagnie j'ai
beau temps aujourd'hui par un mois jean
paul sartre a rien pour vous
attendez une minute à tort oui j'ai
apporté par là ça ne vous ennuierez pas
de jeter ça en passant dans la poubelle
en ebook sur casimir merci de
casimir que c'était ce que du feu qu'est
ce qu'on fait voilà j'ai donc cette
manne et tous les objets auxquels je
tiens le plus alors j'ai décidé de vous
en donner un à chacun bon alors ça c'est
vraiment trop gentil kazimiya c'est un
grand père je suis fier d'être ton ami
il ya
une jolie guitare
avec avec son manche
j'ai aussi
un très beau plat en porcelaine de
limoges
une chambre à air c'est délicieux avec
de la crème chantilly
et puis j'ai si je la trouve vous très
belles poutres y
regarder
c'est beau hein c'est pas pour dire mais
le choix va être difficile je me demande
si nous avons le droit de le priver de
ces objets préférés qu'est-ce que ça
devait être dans l'autre sac alors
lesquels bulli bout et bien écoute
casimir ce sont des objets préférés je
crois qu'on n'a pas le droit de te prive
nos noms sortent on n'a pas le droit
alors tu les gars mais merci quand même
c'est surtout la tension qui compte
sans rien risquer dans le sac je vais
donner un chiffonnier si vous avez
entendu ses cris de joie dans le sacré
un réveil tout neuf une sculpture
moderne de toute beauté et une belle
lampe de chevet
casimir casimir ce sont les objets que
tu voulais nous donner au lieu de les
jeter ah ouais et alors enfin on aurait
dû regarder avant de dire non
une sculpture moderne
c'est vraiment trop bête aux états unis
[Musique]